well johann the you you brought up
social media so i wanted to ask
you know pat brought up radio we talked
about tv even computers
every even video games anything that
fits in that category that's all stuff
you did at home and then it was time for
you to get out the get out the house
walk away and then go live your life and
do what you got to do now this goes
everywhere with you okay so my question
is how much of that is related to
this goes everywhere with you and how
much is the act like there's so many
pros and cons you can talk about with
the phone but is this the biggest
culprit these days you know this is
something i thought about a lot because
i actually at the start of researching
stolen focus
i basically had two stories about why my
attention had gotten
one was i thought well you're just
you're lacking in willpower you're weak
why aren't you strong enough to just not
look at this right
and the other story i had was well
someone invented the smartphone right
that was so and me that way right
so because those were the two stories i
later learned it's much more complicated
what's going on and we need a different
kind of solution but at the start my
response was okay
i'm just sick of this i'm tired of being
wired i want to get my brain back so i
went away for three months with no
smartphone and no laptop how did you
survive without for three months it was
really just fascinating i was really
lucky because uh the film writes to one
of my previous books also i had a bit of
money and i went to this place called
provincetown
in cape cod
and it was interesting because there was
lots of ups and downs but the thing that
amazed me
and i think really speaks to your
question
is you know i was nearly 40. i thought
oh maybe maybe my attentions were coming
to getting older
my attention went back to being as good
as it had been when i was 17. i could
sit and read a book for eight hours and
not get stressed it blew my mind how
much my attention came back and at the
end and i later realized there were lots
of changes i made like to what i eat
in those three months that were also
affecting my attention
and i learned about this from scientists
later but i remember at the end of those
three months
just saying to myself
well i'm never going to go back to how i
used to live why would i go back this is
amazing right the pleasures of focus of
being able to follow through on a goal
the pleasures of being able to think
deeply have deep conversations are so
much greater than the shitty rewards of
getting likes and whatever i'm never
gonna go back and then i got a boat
across to boston to my friend who i'd
left my phone and my laptop with
and within a month i was i never quite
went back to as bad as i've been but i
went like 80 back to where i've been
and i only really understood why when
later i went to interview an amazing man
named dr james williams
dr james williams had worked at the
heart of google part of the machinery
that is up our ability to focus
and pay attention and he was really
uncomfortable with what they were doing
one day he spoke at a tech conference to
the people who are designing the things
that obsess your kids and you know and
all of us
and he said to them
[Music]
if there's anyone here
who wants to live in the world that
we're creating
put up your hand now
and not one of them put up their hand
because they are all being hijacked by
their own creations this was in a group
of students no this is a tech conference
tech designers who are designing
like the stuff that you use all the time
right and and he quit and he became i
would argue the leading expert on
attention in the world and he said to me
look the mistake you made when you went
away for three months and just thought
you could hide from it he said it's like
thinking the solution to air pollution
is for you personally to wear a gas mask
right i mean if i lived in beijing i'd
wear a gas mask right there's a case for
gas masks but we've actually got to
solve the problem instead of just trying
to hide from it so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]